[Music]
what's up people welcome back to the
podcast or welcome today I have my good
buddy Darren Oh lien it's his third time
on the podcast Darren is the super food
hunter to end all super food hunters
he's the author of a great book it's
called super life it's an awesome book
and today we talk about all kinds of
stuff we talk about super foods of
course we talk about lifestyle habits to
reduce anxiety and stress and depression
what else did we talk about
talked about kind of sustainable
business doing things right how to help
the planet to voting with your dollars
right so Darren's got this new business
called Peru cos which is the Beru nut
which is this exotic super nutritious
nut that tastes like better than peanuts
and it's like insanely nutritious so we
talked about that and we have
show-and-tell with all these crazy
superfoods that he has brought us from
Peru and Brazil what is this a bail bail
this is uh yeah this is bail Bob Bob
bail Bob bail Bob and babassu babassu
what is that what is but what's the
difference this is uh this is from a
poem aha
in the in Brazil so this is uh it's got
oil similar to that of coconut oil right
and here we have different variations of
maca right now go the full bowl it's
awesome it's the kind so anyway thanks
for dropping by it's a great episode and
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with Darren oh lean right
now well we're rolling welcome to the
studio and we're talking about this maca
root bulb that I'm that I have in my
hand that you know then I've been eating
maca for a long time I had no idea that
this is what it looks like and that's
black maca so that wow you know that
people think that the characteristics of
the black maca have a lot of more
aphrodisiac kind of potency and there's
less of it so you typically have the
yellow right that's
kind of the biggest and then there's red
maka so then there's some fertility with
women and at the end of the day most of
what's inside it's usually what they're
trying to get into is that on the
outside layer that's where some of the
differences are but the evidence isn't
that strong I really believe that just
taking maca and general is done again
whatever in whatever form gonna hit yeah
I didn't even know there were different
varieties of it yeah that's amazing and
these are all from Peru yeah yeah yeah
so for those that are listening it's
gonna be show until day movement Darren
he brought a case full of his wares all
kinds of exotic superfoods in their
original state so if you're used to just
listening to this podcast you might want
to check out the youtube version so you
can see what all this stuff looks like
and we're gonna get into it today so
awesome man good to have you it's good
their time on the podcast yeah man third
time's a charm ER that's right and and
we didn't even talk about what we're
gonna talk about today but you know
we've gone over your you know for those
that are new to the show we have done
two podcasts the first one was really
kind of about your backstory and sort of
superfoods in a general sense in your
book super life and then the second one
was kind of water focused as I recall
yeah and so today we're just gonna take
it wherever we want to take it I guess
what's uh what have you been doing I
mean since we last spoke you've gone on
a couple adventures I know you went to
Brazil sober timing yeah yeah well you
know when you superfood auntie fund you
find you may go with one intention try
to find something or try to follow up on
something and usually when I come back I
have five or ten things that I'd even
know existed because when you're in the
middle of nowhere and you're in a new
country or in a new area or ecosystem
inevitably on that trail of sometimes
hundreds of hours from hiking to bikes
to water buffalos I've literally been on
water buffalos before you come back and
so when I
was in Brazil years ago I was there in
the Amazonian side which is kind of
technically upper Brazil like northern
to mid is mostly Amazonian geographical
area and rainforest yeah and so I was
looking for other things I was looking
at certain types of palm
acai of course this and the Theobroma
family this thing called capo wasu which
is that i've never even heard that it's
like a it's in the cacao family but it
has a higher fat content some other
properties that are similar but don't
have the kind of the same energy kind of
producing stimulant but delicious I
don't I've never understood why it never
really came about because I've played
with formulating with cacao and Capo's
ooh and it's it's utterly
mouth-wateringly delicious so and was
that something that you were not aware
of before you went on that first
adventure to Brazil that you stumbled
upon or no I had been aware of that from
the Peruvian side so I was aware of the
couple of SU is a Portuguese word so
it's primarily in the Brazilian side so
I had heard of it then I had gotten
samples I had done some research but
ultimately during that trip I had a
Brazilian reach out to me and tell me
about this thing that I had never heard
of before in the sahajiya
and I'm like what's the Sahadi right and
like it's a tropical savanna which is
kind of a cousin or the lower half of
the Brazil is the southern part of
Brazil and and I was like whoa that's a
savanna like that's fascinating and he
talked to me about this this bottle was
eight a tree that comes from there and
this thing called Beru nut and I was
like uh you know I'm smiling
and humbly smiling go on no I've never
heard never my god you're the guy who's
supposed to know all this course right
but that's the beauty
I can never know it mm-hmm it's like the
planet is so big and there's so much
diversity like the humbly I picked a
fantastic career that I can learn for
the rest of my life and so of course
then I was completely fascinated and so
he ends up sending me samples I started
doing some research before they got
there and I was like whoa there's some
high nutrient value to this you know
this nut and as soon as I taste it whoa
I was life had altered at that point the
Peru not yeah yeah because because of
this because my hat of course goes on
many different ways from just the
adventure of finding something new to
the curiosity but also you put the hat
on of what can I do with it and how can
I get it to people especially if it's
highly nutrient dense right
and at the same time supporting the
communities that produce it and we'll
get in to live my NASA part of it
Masum well talk to me in general a
little bit about the Sahadi and the
differences between Sahadi land and
rainforest land because we hear a lot
about the Amazonian rainforest and the
deforestation that's taking place to
provide cattle grazing and growing feed
for cattle I think it's like a football
field a second or something like that
that's getting cleared you don't hear
much of anything about the Sahadi oh
yeah yeah the Amazons about the about
the less I heard it was about the
landmass size of France every year is
being tested and that and the Amazon
saying like let's just say that it's got
the highest PR right it's they are
promoting it and people a lot of working
groups are trying to protect it right
but what is the Sahadi and and and so I
was very much fascinated by that and and
and as soon as I ended up there
I saw it and so now you're looking at a
landmass that is about three states of
Texas it's over a third of the all of
Brazil
that's like saying runnable and Brazil
is you know us and Brazil are about the
same size so so the Sahara is like over
a third of what the United States would
be that's unbelievable it's huge so it's
sort of sub equatorial right below the
equator yeah the rainforest is more
equatorial right yeah
and it's I presume a more arid yeah yes
I mean it changes it's such a vast area
we've been looking at it from Bolivia to
Portugal to to Brazil and it changes a
bit for sure and the diversity changes
and the population of certain botanicals
and trees and birds and and fruits and
all that stuff changes here and there
but ultimately think of it as like a
little bit of a desert II feeling for
the most part with a very interesting
biodiversity and the the that which one
of the things which was very fascinating
we we were you know this is a kind of
thing you can't find out until you're
there and one of the things was number
one we're driving through it and you're
you're fascinating and fascinated and
also holding back tears at the same time
because you're literally seeing
deforestation so it's impacting the
Sahad oh similar in a way that's similar
to the rain for work right and and think
of this so only in the last 40 years no
one really knew other than the people
living in there what the Sahara was they
didn't really do anything with it
that was kind of it Brasilia resurrected
kind of in the center of it
once that happened it get it gained this
attention
and then all of a sudden like oh this is
kind of a poor cousin to the Amazon with
less vegetation that's above ground so
it seems to be a little easier to
justify yeah you have to destroy so
here's the thing so in 40 years the
landmass that's that large they have
destroyed it and the stats are between
fifty to seventy nine percent of that
whole area has been DeForest only in 40
years so that gives you so how does that
sorry to interrupt you but like how does
that occur like what is the mechanism
behind how it how it goes down I would I
would assume you know I'm envisioning
you know relatively poor indigenous
inhabitants who are then offered a check
you know that they can't refuse because
there's no other way to better provide
for their family and they just relent I
mean is that how it happens
for sure I mean so so think about
there's kind of this so from an economic
from a ecological point of view the AHA
do is kind of buffering and tempering
the Amazon there are they're cousins
they need they need they have a
symbiosis right and so when that's
getting disturbed it causes a lot of
instability in the Amazon as well which
then further accelerates everything the
the deforested part you might be
whacking it above ground but here's the
interesting thing
some people experts in country in Brazil
say that the vegetation is because of
deep tap roots because of huge droughts
that the the plants and the bottles ate
a tree and these plants have deep deep
tap roots so they're hitting deep
aquifers so they have a vegetation below
ground that's equal if you flipped it up
as to the the breadth and the width and
the height of the Amazon so you're not
seeing the the biomass that's being
lloyd from the root structures right so
there's this incredible incredibly
robust beautiful vegetation with
extraordinary biodiversity but it
doesn't meet the eye right it's below
ground you have you have 90 million
species of insects you have hundreds of
species of mammals you have tens of
thousand plant diversities you have a
diversity that's comparable to the
Amazon mm-hmm and what are the the sort
of you know alpha land mammals in that
area like what if you're you were you
know trekking through there like what
are you seeing well the funny thing is
we had a we had a you know because of
this sad situation where you have
literally like this line that's drawn
between what's do the forested and then
the forest or whatever is left in that
and we had a situation where we were
going through an area and then out of
the forest runs this anteater that's the
size of a California mountain lion wow
it's huge like huge like nose and so we
we actually in our ultimate wisdom we
tried it kind of like he's out in the
open kind of vulnerable so we kind of
like got jumped out of car and kind of
tried to get him back in in the forest I
don't know whatever that was doing I was
just starting instincts so but you know
it's it's you know it's everything from
different types of foxes and and things
like that there's no large like super
predators but you have a you know when
you have insects when you have birds and
you have few hundred different types of
mammals and 90 million insects you have
a you have the inkling of an incredible
powerful ecosystem right and who are the
who are the interests that are behind
the deforestation is it American you
know
big cattle grazing companies
Brazilian companies like who's who's
doing this who are the perpetrators
I tell you Brazil is so I think they
make us look not as aggressive with meat
production they are so aggressive you
what I was hearing is that you literally
when you buy land they force you as a
mandate to to have cattle like you can't
to precondition of actually even
purchasing in Robert that undertow is
that is we want economic stability but
the the the the subtext of that is
that's cattle mmm-hmm right so they're
pushing this on people and the the meat
consumption in Brazil is just just right
so it's staying in country they're not
export oh yeah they're doing a lot of
that or anything like that and how much
of it is for cattle grazing proper
versus growing the feed for the cattle I
don't know the exact stats but it's done
I mean they're they're the the soy corn
it's three things they're the cattle or
either on it the land the stripped land
or you're growing the feed for that
cattle and in mono a mono mono crop
called yeah I mean I and you when you
literally see it and and now having eyes
of the medicinal plants and the the the
Baruch and nuts and all of that stuff I
can see I can see the economic stability
in that right I can see like oh that's
that's important right and and you don't
have to do this unsustainable thrashing
of the land and and burning of it you
have a gift right there in the ecosystem
and so that kind of gets down to like
well you have to have an economic engine
or I have to be able to make a business
work in order to go back to those people
and back to what you said before which I
didn't quite get to
and that is without a doubt in our
Baruch a project there is no way that we
could even have this business if it
wasn't a hundred percent supported by
the indigenous people because they're on
the land and the land mass is massive so
we've spent years meeting the Chiefs
meeting had villagers travelling around
the areas setting up the infrastructure
because this is a nightmare for a
business it's a nightmare try to write
wild collected it's there's no mono
cropping Beru nuts there's no there's no
it's not happening any person of a neck
you know an entrepreneurial brain who
doesn't understand indigenous work and
understanding the real fair trade of how
to make these people very happy and
they're wild collections and support
them it's a if you plant a tree guess
what you plant it it's gonna take
fifteen years for you to even get the
fruit from it so it's not like hey good
idea let's let's jump into the the Beru
trade here the and it's just and so you
have to spend a lot of time organizing
all of the infrastructure that it takes
yeah yeah well you're literally
inverting the paradigm from one that
sees the forest for that you know
through the trees and instead flip that
to see the tree in the forest think you
know what I mean yeah and and having to
overcome the momentum of what is
sustained you know that culture for so
long to come in and say look there's a
better way there's a more sustainable
way that will empower you long term and
you know feed your children for
generations to come but me Darren white
guy coming down to Brazil you're gonna
have to trust me yeah you know I mean
that's that's a huge obstacle to
overcome and you know many times rich
I've been in that situation like so
many times someone at some point has
offered them something for their land or
some sort of deal whether it's in
country and they want to sell the nuts
or or it's some other medicinal plant
some other country I've been in that
situation so many times and here's the
thing that when you show up it matters a
lot when you sit down and be with them
and eat lunch with them and spend time
with them and get to understand them and
see what they need and really come about
it from that perspective and then are
super consistent what we say is what
we're going to do and we're gonna keep
doing that because they have had so many
I'm talking people in general I'm
talking about small farmers around the
world small collectors around the world
it is the same thing that they have
people who've promised them the world
and then when I actually came they
didn't have an economic stability or
they didn't have a business they wanted
a business but they didn't have the the
understanding of how to run it or
whatever the case is they may have had a
good intention but ultimately these
people go out and do a bunch of work and
then they don't get paid for it and so
then they get you know the the it wears
them out over time and so then you're
the next guy showing up but for us now
it's been you know in terms of bruco you
know it's been two and a half years so
we we basically said listen and this by
the way I think all business should be
done from the foundation on the ground I
think that's that's where a customers
are getting smarter because I've always
believed like treat people as if they
know even if they don't you know and and
that's from a consult a customer point
of view so you know it's it's it's
treating these people like what do you
need what do you what's fair to pay you
and then we'll pay them a little more
with some incentives along the way
because you cannot it's like the lottery
you can't just
give them a bunch of money they need to
grow into that
I know farmers and Peru that I've known
for a decade and when the Chinese came
in and overpaid a hundred times for this
stuff because the and I'm referring to
maca these farmers I understand they
have to take the money and they these
the Chinese were coming in with
suitcases full of money and then
stealing it through the old drug routes
because this is technically legal to
leave the country and that's raw state
oh wow I didn't know that yeah that's
interesting and so then it just becomes
it doesn't become a long-term enterprise
sister scorched-earth situation totally
and then those people usually with all
of that money that they're being paid a
hundred times more what happens it's the
lottery situation so they make a whole
bunch of money they don't understand it
fully because they're indigenous people
and they just know how to work and sofa
so when you get a ton of money that it's
caused family problems and and the same
problems it causes here or they're human
so when you work with them you
understand what they need what's fair
just above that and then incentives
along the way like listen we will pay
you a fair amount over what you're used
to paying and for the next 20 years yeah
it's the consistency right yeah it's
it's creating an infrastructure and a
long-term plan that can weather you know
whether it's drought or a crop fails or
something like that right because we've
talked about this like that's what's
sort of you know sidelined a lot of
these other plays to go down there and
and and develop businesses with these
indigenous plants that they don't have
the infrastructure or you know the kind
of human resources and long-term view to
kind of weather those patterns and so
then a crop fails and then you can't pay
and then there's you know too much of it
or you know whatever like how do you
maintain that level of consistency so
that you engender that trust totally
because you know I'm just envisioning
the small farmer it's like oh here's
dare
he shows up like why should i first of
all why should I believe you I've been
burned you know a million times over and
the cattle industry is offering me this
check like you have to convince me why I
should say no to that big check that's
guaranteed that all my friends are
taking yeah if I don't and I go your
route perhaps I become a pariah in my
community or you know I'm taking why
should I
wet shoulder this risk Yeah right
ultimately you're going at least what
you have on your side is common sense
and sustainability of the environment
often time these people live by the land
they live on the land they live very
simply so they're usually in a situation
that's dire so therefore they'll take
these you know situations so they can
live their living kind of day-to-day so
when you show up more than once and you
have your teams that come back and show
more show up over and over again and you
say listen don't cut all these down do
as much work as you want and will pay
will bite this is what we say will buy
everything you're willing to collect for
the next 20 years and the way it works
is these villages have like
receiverships right where so the various
farmers collect the Peru nuts and they
get deposited into like one location and
then you kind of gather all of those
collections oh right
tons of locations and tens of thousands
of families so it's not agriculture in
the traditional sense of them like
clearing a plot of land and growing
these trees it's just gathering what is
already false or of native to the
lance's so this is it
so that's a borough not this is the
brain so so this is a thing with these
things they have this incredible
incredibly hard shell on them right this
is almost like a stoned yeah yeah very
much so there's others are listening
it's about an inch and a half long about
a little over maybe an inch wide yep so
on the outside it's a fruit layer so
technically it's a seed so there's one
nut per fruit as you can hear it right
if you shake it if you shake it even
here one technically called a droop and
the nut is like a
meter long right it's it's smaller than
a peanut right it's a well so yeah it's
about a gram mmm it's a gram per about
average 25 grams per fruit right and so
the traditional way of extracting the
nut from the shell is what like a sledge
hammer well yeah the interesting thing
traditional traditional meaning this far
back is and again you don't find this
out until you're actually there and you
talk to enough people that have been
involved in this stuff and villages and
stuff and so what they used to do is
they so the only way you can collect
these you can't they're on is a tree but
you can't collect it early yet literally
because the seed is not complete it has
to drop it has to fall on the ground so
this is all fallen fruit so when it
falls then they collect it right so so
so indigenously thousands of years they
used to take it and so at the end of an
amber evening of fire they would throw a
bunch of these on the fire and and when
the fire would go out and they'd wake up
the next morning all of these were
roasted and so then they would eat more
easily be able to break this very hard
shell open and then crack it open it was
arrested not because the anti nutrients
that are in here and its raw state
because it's like a good question people
always ask like well I want to eat them
raw and like well but you can't because
they're not made that way so like
there's a group of foods obviously that
you can cook that bring out the
nutrients so we did all the tests after
roasting and that's where the nutrient
superiority really just blew us away
right so let's take a step back like you
you're the super food hunter even
spending you know I don't know 20 years
going down into these exotic locations
and forests and foraging for you know
crazy exotic superfoods and you got a
whole bunch in front of you right here
you know everything from maca what is
this huge this is bailed out right there
this is so this is bail Bob from Africa
and Madagascar from a bail Bob tree
which is a sacred tree it looks like the
size of a small coconut yes it's a
little ornamental right it hangs and it
drops and the funny thing is that's it's
already dried powder you know some
people ask well how do you get dried
powder it's actually already dried so
you break it and this is what it's like
inside and there's a seed and then you
just you separate the seed in the powder
and literally put it in a bag and you're
getting tons of vitamin C Cal's in yeah
there's a seed in there so don't crunch
on it but you can yeah I don't eat after
yeah so it's a very important food and
in Africa and Madagascar never really
take tooken off I think it's because
it's you know again you're talking with
villagers you're talking with you got a
I sat down with presidents of the
village and in the middle of nowhere and
you have to organize these things so
it's you know I'm one person so some of
these things I have to just you know
manage my time and my resources to
figure that out but you know what I'm
getting at is you know as somebody who
has created this encyclopedia of these
foods and there are nutritional benefits
you've made this decision to like zero
in on the borough not and like really
pioneer the introduction of this
nutritious superfood into the you know
Western world the developed world
marketplace so why the Beruna like what
is it about this not that made you go
all right I'm just gonna put all my
energy into this one thing as opposed to
you know the Bayeux Bob or one of these
other ones also sue or Moringa and the
meringue has got a whole nother story
that you know it was several things
it was the nutritional profile compared
to Indian other nut is far superior so
what is the profile so it's got three
times the fiber of any
which is just ridiculous right and we're
all lacking fiber the protein is
superior than any nut it's close to a
peanut with protein but it's got all the
amino acids which also is not heard of
in a nut so complete amino acid Pro s
profile the antioxidants which is
incredible
[Music]
370 plus percent more than almonds so it
is just this power and then the
micronutrients copper zinc calcium
magnesium just wickedly high in and then
you have a third less calories from fat
than any other nut so you have this and
then on top of the just the Wow of the
nutrients which was hitting me as soon
as I tasted it I was like oh my god
there's no American barrier to entry
because it tastes like up peanut some
people say it tastes like oh you know
popcorn went to bed with a cashew like
it's just this incredible incredible
taste profile on top of the nutrients on
top of the taste and then you know why
we're talking so much about the
environment is because it's so
intimately connected to preserving this
huge land mass and for me rich when I've
spin out so much in the world I am under
no delusion that if we want to do
sustainable things
it's not gonna be necessarily from the
government it's not gonna be from some
great organization that's gonna solve
all of our worldly problems it's
literally I see deforestation from
village to village deforestation doesn't
necessarily just happen by some person
coming in wiping out the landmass of
France it's small things added up over
time
and so I really believe that the and we
know this by creating value back to the
borrows ADA tree and and proving to the
indigenous people that we stand for you
we stand for the environment and we say
what we we are going to do and follow
that up that to me is an actionable
thing that we can do to prevent economic
just environmental destruction yeah if
you want to combat a negative market
force you have to create and produce a
countervailing
sustainable market force with with equal
heft and power right so this is the seed
literally the seed of doing that and how
do you I have a bunch of observations
but first of all like how do you ensure
that that you that this endeavor will
continue to protect these people
preserve the land and sort of empower
them to - you know preserve their
indigenous lifestyle and and to the
extent that they can you know put up a
stop sign to the countervailing market
force that wants to clear the land for
grazing yeah well I think it's
everything we've talked about in terms
of the only way that that can start is
by going and talking to them and seeing
who they are what they are what are
their problems and are they like what is
the organizational structure is it just
a loose affiliation of villages and
farmers is there like elders that you
have to go to like what is it what is it
like when you go in you're like alright
who's the guy I got to talk to yeah yeah
I mean the amount of quote/unquote
meetings and interviews we've had from
the had researchers to the we go to the
universities who's studying this who's
doing their doctoral thesis like we've
had meetings with all these people and
then we're like okay who's the
I that's done the organization who's
also all of the all the processors that
have been trying to make this work in
country who were all they who's the head
organizer organizers and now who's the
head Chiefs because ultimately yeah it's
these Chiefs that are having some sort
of political understanding of what's
going on so you you have to get from as
many angles as possible you got to get
exposed you got to have conversations
exhaustive over and over and over and
say the same thing we are here and then
over time you find those people that
have the same values you find people
that have not done things well because
everyone's human
you have failed NGO reforestation
projects you have all kinds of stories
that you're seeing and so you're at the
end of trips you're you just got
downloaded in a PhD of what this real
situation is and so now kind of the the
aftermath of that is oh that guy does
this so if he if we're gonna plant trees
which we are right he's the head of the
nursery understands graphing he
understands the strength of the tree he
knows the numbers he knows how to
distribute them he knows all of that so
that's the guy and then okay that chief
she's completely on board and it was a
it was a woman to badass one of the
Chiefs is a badass woman was just so
cool she was like in her 30s right Wow
just completely I was just stunned very
smart very articulate and and how do you
prevent them from pulling them off the
trees before they're fully ripe and then
delivering you you know a batch that's
not gonna work well that's our quality
control our standards which is all you
know the the Brazilian standard more
and so we've had horrible situations
where you're seeing and this happens a
lot indigenously they're just processing
this stuff and cracking it and throwing
it in bags that were once you know
fertilizer and like you know you're you
going oh yeah this won't work well this
is endemic in that super food industry
in general and we talked about this a
little bit before you know the Moringa
the the nutritional benefit that you
think you're getting from the Moringa
that you're buying at your natural food
market probably isn't delivering on the
promise that's the case of most of them
because there isn't this kind of quality
control there isn't enough regulation to
ensure that the processing methods are
what they should be and there's an
uneducated or under educated public to
be able to differentiate so so much so
that I mean I think your your estimates
were like basically it's all garbage
like with a very few exceptions when you
go to you know spend your hard-earned
dollars and these things are expensive
for sure you know to make sure that
you're actually getting what you think
you're getting yeah I mean I mean rich
my I never the only reason I started
super food hunting is because and that
wasn't even a term I gave myself for
sure it was because my father was an
agricultural professor from in Minnesota
I grew up around farmers I grew up
around some sense of the business around
it and by playing with these things in
formulating with them and looking at
them how would you not have the morality
and ethics of showing up and seeing
where they're from how they're handled
how do what what's the real history
what's the real usage and how do you
process things to do what my goal is a
catalyst to prevent these things all of
these things in front of me all of these
said superfoods are just a catalyst for
these nutrients to get to people
so that those people can thrive period
that my why is way beyond superfood
hunting because I suffered as a kid I
was having issues and challenges as a
kid I realized finally that what I was
putting in my mouth made a difference in
my brain made a difference in my body
made a difference in my outlook so off
that that was in my DNA so to be able to
go out is it to me and find these things
and preserve the quality and preserve
these things that I've been used for
thousands and thousands of years for
really good reason it is my mission to
make sure that when people are their
hard-earned money and and they're not
getting quality they're not even getting
active compounds that they were meant to
get by by buying these that's a shame
because they're there then walking
around going I didn't do anything for me
right it's it's downright fraudulent and
you're entering a marketplace like
standing on the shoulders of an industry
that for decades and generations has
thrived in an environment of
non-transparency yeah right and we're
now entering this new era you know a
generation of people who grew up on the
internet and expect a certain level of
transparency demanded from the
corporations and the you know the the
companies that they choose to choose to
you know purchase their products from
and there is I'm seeing like a renewed
sense of responsibility from business
owner startups you know not just in food
but across the board to provide that
level of transparency and to connect the
consumer with the not just the processes
but the people that are on the ground
who are creating the products that
they're patronizing yeah and and drop
the transparent like drop the
wall and here they are these are the
real things guess where I had to go you
know you guys so it's like we have this
joke Darren and I like I'll go to like
the fancy erawan market which is like
the natural foods market out here where
everything's super expensive and I'll
peruse the super foods aisle you know
there's just aisles and aisles of like
you know every product you can imagine
and plenty of things I've never heard of
and I'll take pictures of like I'm like
this happened with Moringa is like okay
I need to get I want to get the kind
meringue meringue out like what and so
I'm taking pictures of all the different
options at erawan I'm sending you what
about this one when you're like now okay
what about this one what about this one
it's probably okay yeah I feel like
there are there needs to be some
oversight and standards because I'm more
educated about this stuff than the
average consumer so what if you're just
like hey I heard Darren he told me I
should get this it's cool you go to
whatever is available to you and you're
either overwhelmed with the options or
there's only one on the shelf if that
and you're like well take that yeah and
you showed me the difference between
like a pure Moringa which has this deep
yeah green oh there you have it you have
it look at how beautiful that green is
and all that so it's it's a good like
that's yours by the way
well that's amazing so did you did you
hand harvest this that was yeah that was
done in conjunction with the Navajo
Nation in Arizona I have a friend who
does operations and that the nappy as
they call him the Navajo Nation are
doing a boat big push to move from mono
you know straight up mono I pesticide
agriculture to organic and stuff so
uh-huh that was like a pet project but
it was one of those you know things that
I had to kind of buy my time and I
didn't have enough time to to fully get
into the production of Moringa at the
moment but you have kind of you you do
you're kind of doing this on the side
right like you got a plot of land out in
the desert where you're yeah yeah but
proving uh-huh so I wanted to prove like
yes in the here in the United States I
can grow and find an area
that moranga will thrive right so we did
and I got a bunch of really really
competent harvesters with a lot of
experience in the in the organic world
and we did this little pilot project and
and once we harvested it its friends of
mine who own some companies we did a
little I convinced them to let me you
know use their processing line and we
did it and the nutritional value boo me
away likes old this top hold a like
wholesale one that they sell to most of
the companies out there and then I
pulled the top retail one I'm not going
to name these names but and I I did the
nutritional value of this and and heard
them it was two to three times most of
the micronutrients and so that that goes
back to what I'm saying like and part of
what I want people to get the nutrients
so that they can combat this modern-day
stressful world that's a whole other
conversation in this underwhelming
nutrient food that we have so that you
not pulling around this suffering you
know I want people who freaking live
that's why I'm doing this stuff I'm
fascinated by had but ultimately I want
people to consume the greatest foods in
the world so they can not just exist but
they can actually you know thrive and
have enough energy to kick some ass and
we've live the kind of dream life they
want that's yeah I think that's that's
something that gets lost in the
conversation about nutrition it's not
just about like losing weight all right
you know promoting longevity these are
great things but you know if you can
rejuvenate yourself to a point where you
truly are thriving in an optimal state
then the conversation needs to be about
what you're gonna do with that right and
I think something that
gets underserved in the conversation
about Darren is that I think you know
like you're very clear and you said this
to me many times like I know what I'm
here on earth to do like I'm very clear
about that but this is really like a
spiritual Odyssey for you
tonal person you know and you're coming
from like this profound spiritual place
I've know you've done a lot of work in
that arena and so it's much more than
just like hey healthy food yeah well is
you know talking about addiction hitting
my life you know when my dad I've said
the story so I don't need to get into it
but in 2005 when my dad passed away from
30 years of sobriety and started
drinking again it was when you when I
lost my father there was something that
hit me so bloody deeply through that
pain that I was like Darren sorry
audience could [ __ ] around you know
what I mean it's like you quit dabbling
in this stuff you've been to these
things you've seen things take that
knowledge and do something with it and
that and that to me has never left me it
never will and so it expresses itself in
super foods it expresses itself on other
projects it expresses itself in you know
why I called my book super life is
because ultimately underneath all of it
rich I do want people I want myself I
want you I want the camera guys I want
people to live a super life like I
really do like cuz the the latter is
just pain suffering and existing and
we're all gonna hit that but getting and
cultivating the skills and getting the
nutrient value so that you don't you you
have the you have more tools to deal
with it and think straight and then
figure out the other things that you
need to support yourself if that's
finding a guru if it's finding a
practitioner if it's listening I mean
here's the thing about purpose it's so
easy to
blow it off because it's a whisper and
that whisper is often taken over by a
megaphone of all the other crap the
world tells us we should do you know
that mm-hmm right you freakin story is
right down the center of that you're
this you're a lawyer here if it's
studying this like saying Oh like who is
that right so I get that and I I
listened I listened to my father say
this when I was 9 years old I could
barely see over the dashboard of the car
and I asked my dad don't know ask me how
I did I said what do you want in your
life and my dad said I want to sail
because I was in the Navy and I always
want to have a boat I want to be in the
sunshine and here we are in Minnesota
I want a motorcycle again and feel the
wind on my face and see had a few other
things I I heard that and then I spent
the next 30 years with that man and him
not fulfilling that stuff do you think
that his addiction and his sadness and
his pain is anger of a all this things
that that came from from his childhood
but also not fulfilling his purpose that
he revealed to me and the gift that he
gave me was I heard it but I am gonna
actually do it and somewhere in the eye
I heard that and I felt that right well
a couple things first of all highly
abnormal for a nine-year-old kid to ask
his dad like this profound question
about his life so there's something
about you that is unique in that regard
and the fact that you remember it like
it was such a memorable event in your
life that created like a compass and a
sense of direction and then second to
that is the simplicity of his responses
to that question like I like being on
the water I like the Sun it's like it's
not like oh I need a mansion in a jet or
like it's like very basic
that really I mean the boat you know we
can talk about that but beyond that like
what he really wants is like that sense
of freedom and what he feels like on the
water right and those are not
necessarily tied to socioeconomic status
there they're achievable goals you know
what I mean and the fact that for
whatever reason he became a prisoner of
his conditions and was never able to you
know access those very basic you know
human needs I mean I that's what I love
what is one of the reasons I moved I
like the Sun I like the water like the
mountains here we are yeah you know and
it's there's there's tragedy in that in
some regards it's sad you know the the
cool thing about our relationship my dad
was you know angry drunk you know sober
the scar on my chin that maybe the
audience can see was when my dad got
sober for the first time after he
accidentally catapulted me in the garage
from a slamming the door he didn't know
I was there
in a drum drunken stupor and it
catapulted me into the sea of beer
bottles on a concrete floor and like a
bowling ball I slammed into them broke
him open my chin nearly got cut off and
this was you know for yeah so a symbolic
nature of it of you crashing into beer
bottles to like empty ones or full ones
I they must have been empty yeah right
gotta gotta save those gotta collect
those yeah a trophy to the sure to the
extent to which he imbibed yeah and then
that that's when he got sober for the no
son scaring him but you know he got
scared again and his demons came back
but the cool thing about our
relationship was there was nothing that
was on the left on the table the as we
were adults and we bonded incredibly
like he did get a motorcycle at one
point and ultimately got rid of it for
some other weird-ass reasons that
ultimately
he kind of didn't feel he deserved it
and all this stuff but before he died
there was nothing that I wasn't honest
with him about nothing he wasn't honest
that I know that he wasn't honest with
me and so you guys were good really good
and what what do you think triggered the
relapse after that many years in
sobriety well I think it was it was an
on
dealt with pain so keep in mind in 1941
or two when he was born he was the
youngest of three and his oldest brother
who was 20 years old he was one he was
20 and he got killed in World War two so
their golden child I think he was like
he was dating an actress he was doing
really well he was charismatic he was
all this stuff and then the grief of
that was the petri dish of how my dad
grew up so there was this and then he
you know he he grew up with to engineer
brothers very linear one worked at
boulder at the atmospheric research
center and the other one worked was a
head and went ahead engineers for the
Alaska Pipeline these guys were smart
like I felt stupid around that like like
like they can go read off photographic
memories and like all this stuff and my
dad it's got two parts very smart but
also very empathic mm-hmm right so he's
just like Who am I I'll be a professor
so here's a professor for a while he's
like wait a minute I want to connect to
people so became a counselor wait a
minute I don't want to live in Minnesota
and so he was just kind of a you know a
tennis match inside of himself and
ultimately you know what just
he wasn't fulfilled right and he felt
trapped yeah
yeah and that's heavy for you you know
to carry that around but to be able to
process that and use it as you know an
example of mistakes you don't want to
make in your own life and it kind of
like I said earlier gauge that you know
compass to sort of present forge your
path under Sun so let's get back to the
peruca this stuff Beruna so you've got
like so you make this decision like I'm
gonna make a business out of this like
I'm gonna empower these people and I'm
gonna bring this thing that no one you
know in America or North America the
Western developed world has ever even
really heard of I mean from a marketing
perspective that's a challenge yeah and
I can't imagine the infrastructure I
know you've been laying like the
infrastructure for the past couple years
down there so like you got like boots on
the ground and trucks and like
processing you figured out how to like
crack these things open right you guys
make your own machine to do that like
hot is it like some kind of what is it
like a press well there's there's
several there's several different
cracking mechanisms there's a hydraulic
one that's just mimicking that blade
coming down and and cracking it like
cracking it right here and just break in
there and you can increase that speed
but indigenously like I said way back
then they were thrown on the fire but as
of recently they'll just take a machete
and try to break that open you imagine
how repetitive and inefficient that is
not to mention its scale yeah when it's
exposing it to all kinds of you know
pathogens and stuff so we we have
employed engineers around the world who
are constantly still we want to get it
up to a very high efficiency but we've
collapsed it down into being pretty
efficient but we're also now with the
fruit right so I had this idea when
we're out there so this fruit layer
right right the actual see the the the
seed that in cases the nut yeah so it's
that yeah so it's this fruit which is a
drupe so the the fruit layer
is actually if you you can actually
taste on it so that little so he's got
like a mason jar this sounds like a
trail mix so this is the ultimate
alchemy of trail mix so I've had the
brew nut but I haven't had fruit it's to
have it with it how amazing is that so
when I was out there I saw that's crazy
that the fruit almost tastes like graham
crackers it's crazy
hahaha isn't it that's really it's super
high fiber again with tons of
antioxidants and very low sugar right so
so when I saw this and and when I saw
this and the in we saw a five-year-old
Peru fruit and I looked at it as if it
was a day old and I was like how is it
that that fruit does not break down at
all and I you know I ate it and I was
like it tastes like a fresh one how is
that possible what's going on in the
preservation and the resiliency of that
fruit so in the car and that nine-hour
drive through the Sahara at one point I
grabbed a bunch of these took a pocket
knife and I started peeling all these
and I'm like I'm bringing this back to
the States I'm gonna test this stuff and
that's when the micronutrients and the
antioxidants and the fiber I was like
and then I got back and I did some
dehydration and all this stuff and we're
like holy cow a perfect synergy of trail
mix what is the nutritional profile of
the fruit yeah so it's like a like I
said a ton of the antioxidants a lot
more fiber vitamin E which is great
calcium magnesium vitamin C like
incredible and then that this is just
discarded so again you're looking at a
sustainable structure here's like why
would we throw that away when it's got
such a high and nutrient value and so
that's you know when we're gonna launch
the Kickstarter we're launching it with
the idea
of introducing the fruit the ultimate
the super trail mix right together
because there's I'm always I'm always
blown away at alchemy alchemy in nature
when you see it with medicinal plants
and you see the synergy another great
example of that is coffee for coffee
bean and the fruit and if you do that if
you dry those correctly together the
benefit of the bean with the fruit is
exponentially greater I never anyone on
their own so for example the antioxidant
level is through the roof like the
fruits discard that's another thing like
its are we doing that how come we're not
eating the coffee because it's the cause
it's the call and it as soon as it's
harvested it goes you it ferments but
right away right cements the difference
between this because this doesn't it
stay it it stays as a preservation and
when you start looking at nature nature
will tell you like adaptogens to like
adaptogen being in severe environmental
stressors the beautiful alchemy of that
is wow if we consume them it helps us
deal with stress how crazy is that right
from from chaga to cordyceps to
ashwagandha to astragalus to rhodiola to
schizandra all of these different types
of adaptogen so when I look I'm looking
through the lens of that experience and
so I'm like going there's an alchemy
here there's not only you're you just
experienced the taste alchemy right but
now there's a nutritional superiority of
consuming both together and you're
getting that much more of a complete
again fulfilling my deepest desire of
now I just got rich more nutrients very
happy for it very direct one-on-one way
sure yeah sure the mental health piece
is so important you know I mean here we
are we're in the we're in the wake of
Kate Spade and Anthony Bourdain
you know both making the choice to end
their lives and I think it's it's kind
of created an interest in having a
conversation that we really need to have
about the importance of mental health
and you know I said this on social media
recently like mental health isn't
everything but it's pretty [ __ ] close
yeah right and in my experience you know
I experienced this at our retreat
recently you get a bunch of people
together who are seemingly very
high-functioning or are very
high-functioning and it looks like life
is good and you create a safe container
where they feel like they can be
vulnerable and all you have to do is
poke them and then you realize like
we're all struggling in various ways and
we're not really dealing with these
issues to the extent that they demand
yeah right so what in your experience is
the relationship between some of these
foods and these other practices that
you're adept at and have been exploring
on the mental health equation it's a
great question rich and something that
you know again with my dad being
unstable was intimate in my life and I
you know here's the thing I think that
my dream would be to have people have
better knowledge of access to and the
ability to take care of the foundational
basis and that is sleep well get out in
the Sun drink good water eat a bunch of
plants move your body eliminate
modern-day stressors toxic loads EMF
stuff that's real it's not hokey-pokey
it's real stuff affecting us in the
worst condition
take medication from a qualified I would
say functional medicine doctor who
understands nutritionally and
biochemically and and then put yourself
into positive stressful situations that
evoke the body turning on kind of its
natural instinct of accomplishment of
overcoming so I think in all of those
since it's situations if you do not have
a foundation of of those things it's
like trying to push a boulder uphill if
I'm running around it's very clear on
the evidence and water alone if kids
don't drink water and they go to school
their test results are in the toilet I
forget the exact stat but it's like a
30% that you know impact of water on
yeah
scholastic performance Oh huge yeah I
have some of my book I forget the exact
but it was like a few out like a glass
of water increase their performance by
20 or 30 percent really yeah
the hydration bro is like so destructive
that and the reptilian brain won't even
allow you to think of the thirst because
you have seven to ten percent of
Americans not even drinking an ounce of
water a day they're just going to their
coffee and existing and living on
adrenaline that is their up and go
molecule in their body that was only
meant to get away from a lion but
they're living on it 24/7 you are frying
your hormonal system you're frying your
central nervous system ie brain and we
we expect to then respond to this
modern-day overachieving situation when
you're basic
and also the other thing I said is
proper breathing right yet what I didn't
say is your basic needs of your going
against your basic physiological need so
when when at the root of autism they've
found dehydration lack of nutrition
these kinds of situations so I always
look at which is why I didn't write a
super food book I wrote a super life
book about foundational stuff because I
told the publisher I don't want to write
it on super foods because I don't want
to be put in the thing like this is
gonna cure you or take you away no I
want you to understand that there's
foundational things that you can do that
99% of the people on the planet are
gonna thrive in if you take care of that
so all of these other things and even
medications are like showing up to a
forest fire with a little squirt gun
yeah if you're you could be you know
look here's this beautiful Moringa like
you could be eating this and Beru nuts
all day and like you know the maca and
whatever but if you're you know an
[ __ ] and you're not sleeping well you
hate your boss and and you know you're
you're just not being mindful about
these or intentional about these other
areas of your life like you're not gonna
be healthy you have to understand and
appreciate the delicate balance of all
of these systems and addressing them
holistically and I think it starts with
this realization that most of us the
vast majority of us are living our lives
of reactively when we have a choice to
live intentionally
and don't misunderstand that doesn't
mean you up and quit your job the next
day but you know how do you approach
your sleep every night are you just you
know dozing off to television shows at
2:00 in the morning and waking up at
5:00 or 6:00 because you know you
weren't conscious about how you're
managing your time or what's the first
thing that you're grabbing and the more
like are you reacting and just in a
pattern or a habit that you've always
practiced
or are you making conscious decisions
about how to improve those little things
that don't cost money but require some
conscious energy totally yeah and I
think I think one thing I became aware
of is if you don't intend your life if
you don't set in motion what it is that
you want guess what that choice is gonna
be made for you yeah I know what that's
like yeah you'll be reacting to your
life and so many people are like I just
I just got through the day hahaha oh but
you're doing nothing to do to grow the
the part of you that wants to cultivate
the life that will give you joy it's not
easy mm-hmm but if you don't give your
energy to it then that wolf inside of
you goes hungry and then the other wolf
who is just reacting all the time is
hungry so now you're just addicted to
that weird-ass life getting by next
thing you know you blank a year five
years ten years and you're like what am
i doing what is it a life that I want I
I mean I spend every morning I have to
it's almost like I'm just function I
know let's let's walk through the daily
routine of Darren because something to
behold like what do you get up at like
3:30 every day I did today
did you yeah it's usually it's usually
for what time you got a pet eight eight
yeah it's usually pretty much uh-huh
this is the melatonin drip in my brain
and I feel unlike but so yeah you know
sleep again it's a foundational thing
you mess with that there's no amount of
super food that's gonna get you over the
the recovery and the rest and there the
what your body needs to restore yourself
so so that is for sure without a doubt I
don't compromise on that it takes me a
lot to break the eight o'clock
world yeah no social dinners no I mean
listen of course I will
yeah but I also like I will hedge my bet
okay let's go earlier but so you know
that and then I wake up and go for the
water you know I got my apparatuses
making my water we won't get into that
right now but we talked about that at
length on the last one right and and we
were talking before the podcast with
Julie cuz we got to sort out our water
situation here at the house as long as
it just said oh yeah give you a whole
house yeah we haven't give it a house
system and then I'll get our water it's
some hydrogen action so that and then I
make some sort of super elixir with
several medicinal plants tons of
adaptogens and that's kind of my the
start of them the ritual right so then
I'll go in and that my dog chaga kind of
gives an indication of yeah where you're
on it side mark my head my favorite
super food is so chaga comes in he lays
down get a second sleep I come in and I
then I do a meditation I use some
sometimes I use some brain devices some
helping the right and left brain
communicate through some some light in
some frequency technology and then so
I'll meditate for about thirty minutes
and then I'll just move right into kind
of a stream of consciousness writing
that that is just really centered in the
meditation and then I will you know
sometimes that is working at a problem
if I have one or something on is on my
mind and the other it will always end in
where I'm going and what I'm doing and I
may have said the same thing a thousand
times this project that project did that
like I am always starting my day with
that in my consciousness I believe will
you journal until you arrive at that
level of clarity or do you stop at a
certain page limit or time no I mean
it's it could be five minutes it could
be another thirty
you know it's usually in that zone but
I'll get there pretty quick I mean I've
honed my this is what this is about and
and my tuning fork of ultimately where
I'm going is pretty sharp now but it
feels good it feels good to tune into
that which I want to create so I always
love you know I start with gratitude I
still a lot of things I'm grateful for
and I kind of warm up in the writing
with all that because I don't want to
come out of I need to do that and
therefore all arrive and like all that's
if I want to do it because I'm excited
to put it in the world and generate
write it's more about like what what is
the headspace I want to be in and what
is the energy I want to cultivate that
will propel me in that direction so it's
not about a specific goal necessarily
but kind of a wavelength where you want
to live yeah and then very concretely
cuz I have some very concrete new
projects that I've been cultivating for
years now that are very concrete like
this guy and I'll employ the universe
man I'm I have no qualms about universe
get that agreement signed and anything
that doesn't allow that to sign just
destroy that like I will be that uh-huh
like I will employ the universe as my
assistant to just go and listen for the
highest good right so like I you know
you put a little of that energy to work
to land this incredible abode you know
this branch where you've now live on and
then you know hidden in the woods of the
Malibu of mountains totally hit ya
around mountain lions bobcats hawks owls
is that bobcats still coming by oh yeah
man really easy to glaze in your yard
no oh the Bobcat yeah the Bobcat hasn't
for the last six months but the mountain
lion showed up a couple weeks ago big
big male mountain lion
what does chaga do he didn't see that
one he saw the female mountain lion
I've got an active class and he wanted
to go after her
uh-huh and I pulled him off but that was
good it's good for him to not be afraid
but not good for him if he's actually
gonna fright
yeah that's not an well for him though
but it's humbling because I I live in
the forest and I live in nature and I am
not about to change that I'm not about
to make a footprint to scare these
things away I am a part of them and
they're part of me and we live here
together I'm just walking around with a
90 pound German Shepherd and a machete
case yeah well I want to follow this
thread through of your morning routine
and your daily routine but I want to
pause and reflect a little bit on this
idea of living and intentionally and
with like a focused purpose to make the
point that it's not like a one-time
thing like this is a this is an evolving
journey right and you've recently gone
through kind of a renaissance in your
own perspective about how you're
directing your career like you're a very
enthusiastic guy like you get super
excited about these projects and you
have this kind of moment of reckoning
not too long ago where you realize like
that enthusiasm left you spread too thin
and committed to too many different
projects and you had to kind of like
pause and go what am i doing and you
ended up kind of cleaning house in order
to get focused on the things that are
most important and this is somebody who
I mean how long have you been practicing
the meditation and the journaling right
so it's not it's not like oh I'm clear
like this is always changing and
evolving and and there's you know there
are still blind spots yeah right well
every step you take in the world opens
up a different door so it's not like I
can journal about the same thing cuz a
different door open maybe that week that
month and I didn't know I didn't see
that the universe has got got this more
than me
and so yeah I is humbling rich you know
like there's a zillion things I want to
put in the world and I get super excited
about it and I have every intention that
I'm going to do it
and when I kind of sat with this reality
that I'm like oh I'm not moving this
forward I'm actually suffering and
bleeding a little bit financially and my
time and emotionally and I had to get
rid of an incredible team I had some
incredible women that were champing my
you know what I was doing and it was the
hardest it was the heart one of the
hardest things to kind of go I have to
do this I have to take a timeout and I
that that reassessment to then refocus
on the things that ultimately mattered I
was losing a little bit going oh I
should do this oh I should do it well
because other people are doing that and
I'm like that that was hurting me mm-hmm
and that was humbling so I had yeah I
had a switch and and and and you know
taking a break from the instagrams and
all of that stuff and just going you
know what I am really clear my big
cultivation here is so all this little
stuff that will come come what may right
now and I'm putting some energy into
massive projects right now and I'm so
fired up but also now grounded because
it's a lot of work to put something in
motion and to put teams together and to
you know ultimately some of these things
are gonna ruffle some feathers when they
get out there in a in a really good way
but I'm really excited yeah so how many
people do you have involved in the in
the borough not project for Lucas yeah
so burgers its I have a really really
good
badass kind of I mean he won't say he's
he's the CEO but he is and so Seth is
just incredible when he's traveled with
me in a lot of countries so he
understands so much of what's going on
he's in a place in his career where he
doesn't need money mm-hmm he just
wants to do it right was it awesome and
then I met him he's super cool I quit he
said he's retired like four times or
something like I had and I threw this
atom and he couldn't stop him saw and
then Rodrigo this is the Brazilian who
ultimately introduced me was and was
questioning is like you could could we
do this like I'm Brazilian I want a help
of this thing and then and then he's
turned out so the guy he tried to do it
on his own
well yeah they they they had seen this
thing and they were thinking that it was
possible but they didn't really know and
I think that's why he reached out to me
goes oh if anyone's gonna know if
anyone's gonna help it's this guy so and
then so he's turned out to be just a
badass just works hard and cares and and
then and then Justin who I've worked
with and severall
Seth who has worked with a few times
everyone's just in the right spot you
know and we're just all about doing it
right let's plant trees let's make this
sustainable for the people and let's get
get out the the greatest nut on the
planet why are you doing a Kickstarter
well because you know were were again
we're in this engineering thing where
the the nut the the nuts one thing to
crack which we're spending time
resources and money to do that but it's
also now how to shave this efficiently
the the fruit off of the nut this
doesn't exist so we really want to raise
the awareness and and if there's any
capital great let's let's do that but
it's ultimately the biggest personally
the biggest reason we want to raise
money so we can plant trees like right
now uh-huh
he goes fifteen years giving these trees
out to to the indigenous people so that
they
replant them in the wild we want to get
millions of trees
and that is ultimately why we're
creating this Kickstarter right so how
much are you trying to raise through
that I don't know what we're gonna set
but we're gonna get some eyeballs on
this thing and I I urge everyone to like
go out and and tell your friends and
family because this is really rubber
meets the road voting with your dollars
by you ordering some of the trail mix
you'll get you know an incredible
experience with great nutrition but
you're literally helping an environment
and you're helping the indigenous people
directly because like I said if we're
not in the symbiosis with the people and
the planet this project wouldn't even
exist so that's ultimately our biggest
goal yeah every consumer is empowered
with the ability to shift and change
culture by voting with your dollar right
so you can go and buy what you've always
bought and that ultimately is supporting
you no you you are voting for those
companies to succeed so who are you
voting for are you voting for somebody
who is you know damaging the planet and
poisoning children or are you you know
investing in the future really and
investing in true sustainable
agriculture that's empowering indigenous
people and also at the same time
nourishing your body you know in a in a
profound way so you rolled this thing
out and when did these first become
available because they've been there at
erawan like you can buy it either at Sun
Life you know Khalil's job friend of the
podcast yeah so I'm seeing them around
and what's great I mean first of all I
haven't even said it they're like
incredibly delicious dude they're like
they're so tasty that they're addictive
and even like my daughter Mathis she
goes to sonlife and she buys them she's
like oh my god she's like that's your
friend Darren's company I can't like if
I eat them I have to eat like the whole
bag like I can't stop eating them
they're so good and she's finicky you
know like she's not easy to please so
you know for an adolescent you know
teenager to enjoy a food that's
super good for you that's like that's
such a win you know that's what we found
the kids would you know our friend Neil
Strauss
right yeah so he sent me a video of his
son ten haha two years old crying on
video I'm like I died laughing so the
thing is again the the no barrier to
taste entry for Americans plus the
nutrients plus good for the environment
that's why I did it but that's why I
focused on Bru cos to like this this
called me this wasn't even my this
wasn't even a choice I had to do it yeah
it's not like like maca is an acquired
taste like Moringa is very exotic but
the Beruna meets the American palate
like where it's at because it does taste
very it's like a better tasting version
of a peanut it's better I think it's
better and to know that the nutritional
profile like blows a peanut away and and
is better than an almond like I love
almonds but the water input for almonds
is insane you know so I feel like I have
this weird pang of guilt every time I'm
eating almonds or making my own almond
milk
yeah well it's it's the amount of water
they use for one year of cultivation of
almonds is as much as all of LA uses
that's crazy
all of LA yeah I mean it's not as bad as
beef or dairy to be clear but like in
terms of the plant kingdom
it's them I think it might be one of
those water intensive plants to grow and
they grow them like crazy here in
California an area where you know
drought is a very real thing and this is
this is wild this is no there's no
outside water that's what what what it
taps into an aquifer and what rains on
it like that's it and just to be fair
you know there is a it's not without its
carbon footprint though because you got
to import these things for Brazil so we
can't they can you grow them here or
they is
something about the soladu and yeah it's
a very very particular biome we haven't
found that it would thrive and you would
take you probably two to three cycles of
the tree growing let's say it matured in
15 years
it may die off in the next 30 so you
don't you don't really know but I I'm a
firm believer that went up the planet
has chose a particular area to grow
something then there's a reason for it
and I like to my view is outweighing the
carbon footprint is allowing for the
indigenous people to thrive for the
planet to be to the the Sahara to be
resurrected and for people to have
better nutrients and it's a prophylactic
against the encroaching you know
deforestation of the cattle industry so
our calculation is that there's far far
outweighs the footprint of that and
again we're very very conscious of
utilizing it in the most sustainable way
and that's why we've taken two and a
half years to to get it to where it can
be talked about and shared now are you
like you're selling these from the
website right now yeah you get them a
nationwide are where are you shipping
worldwide like where we're starting to
open up the world but we're a little far
from that but certainly nationwide brouk
is calm or amazon and do you want to
maintain the direct-to-consumer model or
is the intention that you'll have this
in you know retail grocery stores
yeah we're not we're not opposed to that
I like the idea of people getting it
directly because it just allows it
allows for efficiency economic
efficiencies but you know a few
retailers want it we're not gonna say no
we have some big big distributors bake
bake and I'm not gonna name and now
because we're under agreements and stuff
but we have some of the biggest that
want them right now and
again there might be a lot of people
coming into this wanting it but to
actually have a sustainable supply is
very very very difficult there's no end
to like what you can do to you could
make butters out of this if you tried to
make a milk out of it yes yeah milks
insane
butters insane Neil Strauss is wife made
remember those do you have those oh yeah
yeah they're cups yeah really good crazy
so we got to be part of the plan right
and then we have a Himalayan salt dusted
nut that is it's just out of your mind
delicious so yeah we have some plans
it's exciting man totally exciting yeah
so what do you think like the the
timeframe is to like get this into
mainstream awareness and everybody's
pantries I'm hoping in the next month
men in the next month Wow yeah I think
we were I mean I want it I want to get
attraction straightaway because we're
coming in to harvest season you guys are
sitting on a bounty of it can you
fulfill the man we can fulfill a lot of
demand right now and we want to know
more of what that demand is so we can go
gather like right now like an infinite
amount so yeah we're able to to you know
what we've been doing is we're sitting
on a large supply for this very reason
right here so right that's exciting yeah
yeah it's you know it's just again I'm
in this place in the career I'm not
doing it for the money per se I'm doing
it because it's the right thing to do
and again I want there's nothing gives
me greater joy than to see you eat those
and to see other people eat them because
I know all of what we've discussed today
is real and it's something that we've
worked very hard and you're getting
something incredible for your body and
that to me I knew the moment I started
superfood hunting I started giving my
formulas away to people that just is
like the biggest puts a biggest smile on
my face
it's cool man yeah well I want to wind
this down but you know before we kind of
close the book on this on this subject
this theme of mental health because it's
it has been I mean look it's been
weighing on me heavily and I haven't
spoken about it very directly but you
know Anthony Bourdain represents this
kind of person that was almost magical
like he he you know he transcended the
silos in which we now find ourselves
like he could communicate with a trump
supporter just as well as he could
communicate with an Obama supporter like
there was no political divide when it
came to his sort of fan base and as a
guy I mean he lived a life very similar
to yours like he was a he was a he was a
he was a food hunter he was that he was
a an explorer of cultures you know and
he devoted his life to to visiting these
indigenous cultures all over the world
and and took the time to commune with
them to understand them to literally
break bread with them in an effort to
like make the world a little bit smaller
yeah you know and what you've done is I
see a lot of similarities and I feel
like we need more of that now we need
more of the you know the these these
people who can bridge that divide and
help us communicate better and you know
on a personal level like he was the
expression of like kind of like every
guy's dream like he gets to travel the
world and he eats this amazing food and
he gets to share it and make these
amazing TV shows out of it and I think
that is part and parcel of why it was so
impactful when he made the choice to
depart the planet and the way that he
did and if there is a silver lining in
that beyond just celebrating his life
it's that we can have a conversation
about focusing on mental health trying
to
invest in our well-being beyond beyond
just you know fitness or weight loss to
get really real with something that I
think is most people in our anxiety
ridden overly stressed you know scroll
obsessed culture that is leaving us
depleted and depressed and and and
despondent in many cases so to the
extent that you can like leave us by
imparting a little bit of wisdom about
how some of these foods that you've
explored could help benefit people's
mental well-being or some lifestyle
practices that people can begin to
incorporate into their own lives that
might begin to you know address and you
know provide a little bit of comfort and
ease not and not this is not to say like
Western medicine doesn't have its place
in the conversation about depression
specifically but more to the point that
we have more control over these things
than I think we've been led to believe
I agree hundred percent and just to
touch on that Anthony Bourdain is will
be missed because of that spirit that he
had and for what he did and without a
doubt I was impacted for ten years he
had to be like a sort of beacon for you
yeah when you have people like him and
you have like Dan Buettner and you have
people that have hit the trail you don't
think that I'm like on you have Kris
Killam right medicine hunter like all
these people are people that I totally
respect because it's almost like a blue
collar rubber reached the road like so
you're seeing this truth and what
they're finding and then they're sharing
it so he's he was doing that and I
respect that and you know someone that
you know people have been wanting to do
a superfood hunting show for ten years
so I've always looked at him as he's
it's the counter to that yeah he was the
guy doing that I think back to your
you know like I alluded to it before in
the foundational side of it I think I
think breathing is a very very powerful
thing that you can do and I'm not just
saying like breathe I'm saying like nose
breathing shut your mouth breathe
through the nose do that multiple times
a day if you do it before you eat which
would help once you start breathing
through your nose it turns your your
stress sympathetic nervous system it
turns starts to turn that off and it
turns immediate state change exactly so
the parasympathetic and then you can get
into you know the oxygen advantage is a
great book that talks about that you
should get that guy on the podcast and
Brian Mackenzie he's doing some
interesting Brian who did he partner
with some guy from writing a book or
he's doing some research on this he's
doing a I'm not going to reveal too much
but he's doing some stuff that would be
accessible also a big shout out to him
he just had a severe neck injury I in
surgery so we just wish him well but
thinking about him a lot so yeah he's
doing a lot obviously wim HOF he was
just really gave it into the mainstream
yeah huge and then Laird Laird Hamilton
Gabby Reece and Meno they're you know
friends of mine and but realizing how
powerful like I've done I've done DMT
I've done ayahuasca I've done things
like that but when I realized that oh it
really is the breath it isn't the you
know there's a place for psychedelics
and all that stuff in our culture there
always has been for me and like I see
that door that's open just through
breathing exercises every morning I
didn't say that in my morning thing I do
breath work so I do all nose breathing
and I do some inhale hold some exhale
holds and stuff like that and that is
there a specific protocol that you
adhere to that people who are listening
can find somewhere online or is there a
condition like where can people learn
more well there's certainly a lot of
tradition but again wim HOF has some
stuff xbt life comm with Gabby and Rhys
have a lot of stuff on it I have a very
simple thing
inhale for five count hold for five
count exhale for five count hold for
five count and then just keep repeating
that right and that will completely
shift your brain in your state and and
do it all through the nose these are
ancient practices it just it's great how
it's now come back around and now the
performance guys and the and the you
know all of these different types of
people are like oh wow the breath stuff
I mean this is ancient to mo breathing
from the the monks that would go out
naked and put sheets of cold wet cloth
on there and they generate so much heat
they drive the damn mouth off so so
breath is huge in changing the brain
state and then you have you know
obviously food and you and I both agree
go for plants and eat as many as you can
get the nutrient-rich ones and there's a
place for super foods right the place is
because of a modern-day stripped out
food and overstressed we need these damn
plants to counteract that stress
obviously move exercise move your bodies
change I mean I remember my master's
program in psychology one lady was kind
of freaking out like going through a
process and Volvo on and the the PhD
teacher said I hear you could you just
run around the class she was like oh
just take a little jog because that
little jog that took 10 seconds changed
her complete state right so we
underestimate how powerful these
foundational things are and then I would
say and then quickly is I would also
eliminate electromagnetic fields as much
as possible
turn off your damn Wi-Fi at night don't
sleep with that you don't need it you're
not looking at your turn off that state
of stress get out in the damn Sun with
no sunscreen if your shame on you if
you're freaked about the Sun Elyse
do it in the first few minutes without
sunscreen because 9 SPF sunscreen cuts
down your vitamin D production by 99%
and your vitamin D production is behind
the immune system cardiovascular disease
osteoporosis diabetes like all of that
stuff so these are again
these are found very very basic
foundational things that when you do
these things it sets your mind straight
and then I would say yes in the
superfood world there's some cool things
you can get into I don't know what the
availability is but I do know that it's
starting to be out out there so the
coffee fruit and that is clear science
friends of mine developed that I was
down in in Veracruz Mexico looking at
the process and looking how they figured
out how to use the fruit and the bean
and the cool thing that they found out
and they did clinical trials on this is
that alchemy increase the biogenesis of
the brain so it increased o BDNF
brain-derived neurotropic factors just
by taking that alchemy alone this is not
drinking coffee this is a dried bean
with very little caffeine and the fruit
and that L can be turned on neurogenesis
is you eat it like a nut Corazon outter
no it's a powder and now there's some
companies that are starting to have it
in there and then and then tumor owns
and curcumin or with the tumeric are
also showing to have BDNF so there's
zero evidence to support at any point
not taking tumeric right right so just
consume tumeric and that's something
some herbs if you can like get the raw
tumeric root yeah you know at the market
don't lie the powder because you don't
know how that was process yeah unless
you know that you know unless you know
where it's coming from or a reputable
company you can do that and then get a
higher concentration and then if you
have some severe inflammatory such
situations which a lot of people do then
get concentrations of curcumin which
will help the in
inflammatory thing but and again then
you know there's several super foods you
can use for helping the brain but again
water right start with water get your
water in yeah and I think really I think
it's important to contextualize super
foods like if you're eating a junk food
diet but you're you know then you've
finished the day every day with to
market or something you know yeah I'm
gonna max like these are these are like
you know these are the sprinkles on top
of the cupcake right but you front your
foundation has done solid yeah but you
know I see both some people start with a
bunch of super foods eating crap and
then they start to feel better and then
they start eliminating right I've seen
both sides right or the other side right
so you're you know eating good and and
doing everything right and then you're
adding the super foods in and oftentimes
your your sensitivity you'll be able to
feel it but I want to get away from
feeling because it's like you know that
apple a day keeps the doctor away
you're not eating an apple going yeah
I'm gonna run up a mountain no it's the
same thing like consistency with super
foods drinking your you know shout out
to taro and for somatic mushrooms on a
daily basis like that's an easy way to
incorporate some of these some of these
super foods and just consistency because
we're getting bombarded with stress and
adrenaline and toxins so let's get is
consistent with healthy eating lots of
plants and a bunch of superfoods what do
you say you know there's a sort of
countervailing argument out there like
there's no such thing as a superfood
there's food right well yeah well of
course there is so you know let's use a
very extreme example it's so calorie for
calorie you're getting a difference as
opposed to a bologna sandwich as opposed
to you know leaves of moranga and a
salad right so you're getting so
superfood really is per calorie how how
many nutrients you're getting per per
caloric intake so when you look at
something like Moringa you're getting
35 antioxidants and calcium magnesium
potassium and they call it a vitamin
tree for God's sakes so so an ounce of
that compared to an ounce of a doughnut
is is not even remotely the same so so
that's where the you know right get the
nutrient density in so that you can get
what your body needs to counteract the I
think that's a good reply you know I
think sometimes the word superfoods gets
bandied about a little too liberally
yeah but in truth like these are foods
that are incredibly future you know
their nutritional value exceeds that of
the typical food that you're coming
across
yeah and they don't they need not be
super exotic I mean you're you know
you're sort of in that world but well
like blueberries right you know try to
get some wild blueberries eat those
every day they know that that that is
doing some phenomenal things around with
the stem cells and things like that and
we know that that that is not to mention
antioxidants so it's like be consistent
like it's not it's not rocket science
easier don't get caught into fads that
kind of take you away from these
incredibly nutrient-rich foods because
you're buying into this weird-ass fad
you know right so speaking of fads I'm
gonna get cream for saying this back the
final question the 800-pound gorilla in
the room yeah will the Beruna kick you
out of ketosis that is so funny that
it's so funny
depends on how many carbs you had that
day I guess you know there's a there's a
there's this this sort of percolating
movement around a plant-based ketogenic
diet mmm-hmm there might be something
interesting there mm-hmm you know the
more I hear about it the less dismissive
I am of them I mean they're listen this
could be a whole big conversation right
but they're let's just say that there's
applications for it where it gets gnarly
in terms of true ketosis actually being
in ketosis and I think Tim Ferriss even
met
one day is like now I think am I looking
at this 98% of the people doing ketosis
are actually not in ketosis so they're
kind of living this kind of ketosis like
life and eating this way so you're not
actually in these ketone burning fat
burning zones you're eating a very low
carbohydrate diet yeah and the danger is
the the low micronutrient thing that I
see that's that that's the crazy side of
it when you're you know when you you
can't also eat a high protein diet
because there's insulin that the body
needs in order for the protein to be
utilized to and that's what people don't
understand like protein utilization
needs insulin just like carbohydrates
need insulin so true ketosis you have to
actually peel down protein quite a bit
for your body to actually then go into
ketosis
right but you know I so from a
sustainable long term plan ketosis is a
really bad idea
again there's certain you know
conditions that ketosis may be able to
jump you out of and help you through and
there's some evidence to that but as it
is by no means meant to be taken on as a
lifestyle yeah I had falter long ago on
the podcast I love this the leading
scientist in the field of longevity and
he was very clear I mean this is a guy
who's probably gonna win the Nobel Prize
I think he was pretty close to already
winning it and he he was unequivocal
yeah that like eating a ketogenic diet
is the worst thing that you can do for
longevity yeah and we could do a whole
podcast on this I don't want to get ya
weeds on this meat maybe we should do
that and we will do that and we got
through this whole podcast without the
word vegan coming up once
well you did say eat plants yeah cuz
it's like you know look you know I think
like you like
I have my personal reasons for for for
eating that way and and I thrive and
some friends of mine who are not eating
this way say that I'm some sort of
you're the outlier outlier or that oh
because you have access to certain super
foods that no one else would have app
access to my my thought is like okay
that's not entirely true but if you look
at food from a nutrient density
responsibility then yeah I think it's a
it's a poor choice to eat meat for the
demand that your body has to go through
in order to break it down and use anyway
just from that let's just just from that
point of view and you know 20 to 30
percent of that said meat whatever you
eat is is undigested and in future
findings are therefore you're having
toxins but anyway it's a Pandora's box
but yeah it's an inefficiency from my
point of view I wanted to eliminate the
middleman like why would I spend so much
energy breaking down flesh of another
being when I can have Veruca nuts and
Moringa has got tons of the amino acids
and the amino acid cycle and recycle in
the body which a lot of people don't
talk about the the body is really
efficient doesn't want to get rid of
amino acids so it wants to save them and
yeah that's something that Brendan
brazier talks a lot about like net
energy gain you know the amount of
energy that that the demand that you're
placing on your body to digest you know
a steak for example it takes it takes a
toll so where do you come out and you
know where do you net out in terms of
what you're gaining versus what you have
to expend in order to metabolize
something like that sure but we can talk
more about that again come back any time
my friend thank you I'm super excited
about the Beruna verrucas is the name of
the company I should say in full
disclosure that you were kind enough to
allow me to be an affiliate of the
company so I'm really excited to be
aligned with you in that
a I love supporting my friends and I
love supporting even more than that I
love supporting friends who are trying
to do good and creating new paradigms
for how to do business right so I
applaud you for that
and then crowd to be aligned with you
yeah we're on this mission in my little
way so if people are excited about
getting their hands on a package Beruna
it's like how do they do that
Baruch is calm you know aru Kas calm or
Amazon right cool and if you want to
support the podcast you can go to Peru
cos ba are you Kas calm for its lush
rich roll it won't cost you anything
extra but these guys will know that that
you came to them through the podcast and
the podcast will be rewarded so that I
can continue to pay all the people that
helped put on the show and continue to
deliver the best podcast that I possibly
can for you so I'd appreciate it if you
don't please support the Kickstarter
yeah and the Kickstarter so as of the
date of this recording it's not live yet
right but by the time we put this up
it'll be so I will put a link to the
Kickstarter in the show notes on the
episode page average roll calm and I'll
share it on social media and all that
kind of stuff so excited to support you
in that as we appreciate you right on
that yeah in the meantime if you want to
learn more about Darren you can pick up
his book super life it's in paperback
now yeah you know did you do you you're
the boss part of it part of it I was
like yeah I gotta go it's work man it is
now and it's is super life calm still
play for people to go and Baruch is calm
and ruby's doc yeah cool man all right
we'll come back well well pick a subject
and deep dive on it cuz I could talk to
you for hours and hours and
all right thanks man much like that cool
piece that's maruca's
[Music]